[Music]  uh  [Music]  he's over here  [Music]  get him get him  [Music]  god  [Music]  and round we go away bats  rides  over no boss don't wait you can't you  hit us  sorry boys  it pays your money and it takes your  chances  [Applause]  [Music]  i don't believe this you're through zuko  forever  is that so birdie boy  huh  i've waited a long time  [Music]  keep away from me  [Music]  no  don't  please  robin  enough you can't let your emotions get  the best of you  stuff your advice batman you and your  stone cold heart you don't know how i  feel how could you  batman i  i didn't mean a i'm sorry  [Applause]  [Music]  uh  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  you were right you know not bringing me  along  you knew i'd take it too personally  it wasn't that robin  it wasn't that at all  zuko's taken so much  caused you so much pain  i couldn't stand the thought that he  might  take you  too  come on partner  it's been a long night  [Music]  so  [Music]  you